but we have this uh breaking news coming
out of the state department and i'll
tell you the first
and the weirdest thing nobody's written
about this we were sitting here waiting
all day there's a big announcement mike
pompeo said executive action
was coming later today it was going to
be big news and a lot of people were
wondering would this be
trump firing off that executive order
over foreign election interference
finally taking control and winning the
election and uh no
it's u.s imposes sanctions on people's
republic of china actors
linked to malign activities so there's a
lot to do with mass surveillance
military modernization human rights
abuses
and the south china sea and it's about
sanctions against
specific members of the chinese
communist party who of course the state
department uh
trump's administration have been railing
against a whole lot so it's not
what a lot of trump's peter's trump
supporters were crossing their fingers
for
but it is still pretty significant
action from the the you know the latest
actions we've seen from the us
government one of the biggest impacts
that i can
say will will hit you is that when you
go to best buy
and you want to get that fancy little
gimbal to film things with or you want a
drone
you ain't going to get it us government
adds dji to
commerce blacklist over ties to the
chinese government
american companies will be forbidden
from exporting technology to the drone
maker so
perhaps we can still end up getting it
here it doesn't seem like it'd be
likely i don't know what do you guys
know about this what's going on with the
dji thing
i think it's generally they've been
added to this uh blacklist that means
that u.s companies can't
export technology to them so they can
still send it here then yeah i think
like huawei can still for example cell
phones in the us but they just can't
you know buy u.s like semiconductor
chips that's kind of weird because i it
wasn't like
par the part part of the reason why we
weren't buying technology from china is
because they're putting secret stuff in
it to spy on us
yeah i mean yes okay all right but i
think like
legally this commerce department entity
list is only like can
prevent u.s companies from exporting
things or from selling
technology to them right yeah so but
you're about to buy whatever you want i
guess
yeah so i think it's about time we uh we
ramped up this is my opinion maybe you
know you guys are the experts
um maybe we should sanction china to an
absolutely absurd degree across the
board until they end what they're doing
to the weaker muslims
well you'd need to get wall street on
board with that and that might be pretty
challenging
um i i got a shed full of pitchforks and
torches you got you got a couple
thousand people maybe we can occupy wall
street
and uh has that ever been tried before i
don't think so have careers ever been
built on that before
now interestingly i don't it actually it
was tried they never actually did
they never made it to wall street they
went to zuccotti park down the road
i was i was there the day they walked
into zupat coddy park
it was weird yeah very weird but uh we
we have
what disney did mulan in you know where
they were
where they're where they have
concentration camps and then they
thank in education camps right they're
not saying there's
concentration they're just trying
they're just trying to vocational
training yeah
to lift them out of poverty isn't that
right and to prevent extremism that's
right yeah
yes yes so disney famously
thanked the uh what was it called the
xinjiang public security bureau
yeah yeah a country that has public
security bureaus and ministry of
security
yeah amazing and they kind of defended
themselves by going like well we're just
supposed to thank the
you know the areas that helped us you
know we filmed lots of places
yeah some had concentration camps
apparently
some some of the people we thanked were
responsible for those concentration
camps you know
yeah it's not that we're thanking them
for the genocide
no no it's that we're just grateful that
some of these people won't be alive
anymore
well well it's a family guy joke by the
way
the official chinese communist stance is
that this is vocational
training centers that are a part of a
poverty aviation scheme
to help train poor rural workers to
learn
chinese and find employment and they
have to shave their heads and make them
wear jumpsuits right
it's just like it's almost it's almost
like a beautiful
work of art the way that they've managed
to make all this propaganda feed into
each other because
one of the biggest propaganda elements
that they use in china is
we've lifted millions of people out of
poverty and they'll use that as like
a human rights thing like they'll be
like whenever like human rights day
rolls around like december 10th
uh they'll be like you know our biggest
human rights achievement is
lifting millions of people out of
poverty even though
they destroyed the economy uh in the
first place
and then when they backed off and
stopped you know controlling
everything and let people make money
again people lifted themselves out of
poverty
but the other part of it is they kind of
use that to cover up all their other
human rights atrocities
so if you talk about you know being out
of poverty as a human right that's
that's so so so just you know we kind of
made some
uh i guess we can call it the uh a dark
humor
crude joke very very dark but but i did
kind of rip off family guy in that one
from
in my defense but uh considering the
actual severity of the things that china
is doing particularly in this
particularly in this area
shouldn't we stop american companies
from investing in this kind of stuff or
from having factories from having
production
in china until they stopped doing this
yeah as i said earlier it's an issue of
like
people don't think of china as like a
horrible authoritarian regime that has
concentration camps
they think of it because china has been
very successful at a soft power push and
buying off
it's called elite capture uh basically
buying off politicians people in the
media
wall street like you said wall street uh
so it's just an issue of like
most americans don't know if like
americans really understood
what was happening i don't think they
would tolerate nike
trying to you know just shoot down a
forced labor bill
i mean they're doing it they are doing
that i don't think people really know
about that no
they don't and that's kind of scary you
know i've had conversations with uh uh i
had a friend i have a friend from
ukraine
and when i was there during the big you
know 2013-24 i think was 24
2013 when they had the the big protest
that ultimately led to separatist
movement and conflict
i was talking to a friend who uh was
talking about how she's gonna make the
world a better place
very lefty leftist kind of mentality and
i said but do you really believe that i
mean the computer you're using was made
at the foxconn labs in
in in china where people are walking off
the buildings in mass suicide because of
how horrific the conditions are
and she had no idea and it actually made
her cry when she
she was like i but i'm trying to help my
people i'm like yeah she was like i'm
trying to help the world be better and i
said no no no
you're trying to help yourself and your
community and i'm fine with that i can
respect that you know you want the
people in
where you live to do better but you
realize the fact that you have that
computer and that phone
you have people working in essentially
slave labor conditions
jammed in these tiny boxes and it's so
bad they
they actually put up suicide nets around
the building to catch people from just
walking off the edge
i was like when you give them money
you're propping that system up and
you're actually making it worse
that kind of made her you know it's kind
of harsh she kind of had a hard
realization of what was going on you
know well actually i think to an extent
if people were
focused more on building up their
communities uh
you know the the issues like the when
china joined the world trade
organization like
american manufacturing got gutted lots
of jobs went
to china you know it's it's insane that
because of you know various regulations
it's cheaper to
make stuff in china and sail it all the
way around the world
rather than having it made you're
telling me man down the street boards
really skateboards the wood comes from
canada
they ship it to china they make it into
a skateboard and ship it back to the us
now some of that's been changing a bit
now some of the manufacturing's done in
mexico but that was always the craziest
thing to me
they're like we make our boards from 100
pure rock canadian maple and i'm like
wow where's your factory in china
so you get the wood from canada send it
to china and then send it back that's
insane
and and that is the cheaper option
exactly that's something
and it's because the people in china are
being paid trash
and there's no you know look if you hire
someone in north america
guess what you got to pay taxes you got
to pay health care and you already got
in in many circumstances
and the wages are typically much higher
so these big companies have found a way
to essentially extract what's what's
left of the value of the us and china
has found a way
because what essentially happens is the
american workers lose their jobs and
make no money then they eventually can't
even buy the product
so the rich people extract the money
from the poor people and then the people
getting paid are in china
and then eventually there's nothing left
for the people in this in this country
yep it's a it's a win-win for the super
rich that was
essentially a blueprint of what henry
kissinger
richard nixon and david rockefeller had
proposed when they went
to china and quote opened up china to
the rest of the world
and that was such a significant meeting
and we still have to understand
the person who who essentially blue
planned this who made this happen henry
kissinger
he's still around being rewarded and
seen as some great kind of
diplomat meanwhile when we actually see
the ramifications of his actions
the consequences are severe and they
don't work out in anyone's favor
except for the super rich so i don't
know if you guys know a lot about the
opening of china but
i think you guys probably know more than
me about that
well gosh that's a huge did you see that
uh kissinger
was in the news a few weeks ago for
advising biden
to basically reset relations with china
wow yeah so the same guy who made the
blueprints is now telling biden
well trump trump fired him he uh he
purged the advisory board of the
pentagon which included kissinger i was
i was honestly shocked to hear that he
had a position that he could still be
fired from i know
the man he advises the pope okay
barack obama's national security adviser
says
that he no no no there's a different one
i believe his name was o'neil said that
he takes his daily orders from henry
kissinger when he was the acting
national security adviser
so so kissinger has a lot of influence a
lot of powers but we see where his
allegiance
lies especially with the policies that
he set forward
that had these huge ramifications and
essentially destroyed
all the manufacturing blue-collar
middle-class jobs and they took them and
replaced them in china where now we have
all of our goods all of our resources
sent to them
to be processed by sometimes slaves
sometimes the uyghurs
sometimes by individuals will have no
other option but to make your little
goods and they send them back to you so
the super rich could sell you them on
amazon and walmart
walmart walmart who's investing in in
wuhan
i don't know if people knew this but
walmart is investing a huge
substantial amount of their profits to
wuhan
of all places in the world so it's a
safer investment think about it
in the united states we protect the
little guy to the best of our abilities
not perfect by any means the elites
certainly extract value
and can suppress and oppress you know uh
workers and unions and things like that
not that unions are perfect at all by
any stretch of the imagination
but with you know investment into china
you know that if your company is
successful the chinese communist party
will put the boot down on anyone who
dares oppose you
so you think about the risks in the
united states labor laws health care uh
why should we have to worry about the
little people
the elites in this country have found a
way to extract the value
partly by sending things be manufactured
for dirt wages in china
and then once they've gutted the
manufacturing base of this country and
everyone's settled with ridiculous debt
and the only way people can think to get
a job is to go to college rack up
massive debt and then they can't find a
job
that sounds familiar the elites will
just leave these are people with tons of
money
they've probably got money in panama or
wherever they were storing it cayman
islands or whatever
and they can easily just be like well
you know we've extracted all that we can
out of this country it's nothing left
but a withered husk
time to go to china invest in the in the
real estate or or the companies there
and then you have protections based on
the
authoritarianism of that nation they're
kind of screwing themselves though
really i don't have to say that because
they
believe the chinese communist party will
not screw them
and completely like so many people have
been screwed going into china these
businesses
tech companies um famously a few years
ago there was like a
u.s wind turbine manufacturer who made
the solar
not solar the wind turbines for wind
power and
they found out that their chinese joint
venture partner because legally you must
have a chinese company work with you
when you go into china you cannot party
sells
you have to have if you have more than
50 employees in china you must have a
chinese communist party branch
within your company this is law
and then they found out that their
partner was basically
replacing all of that they had stolen
their
property like intellectual property and
had replaced
their the stuff in their wind turbines
with their knockoff version
wow and they did something amazing were
able to be
take away all of their business and this
is not like an isolated instance it
happened to segway
yes there was there was there was a
chinese knockoff segway
uh that stole their technology got so
much bigger and then they bought segway
wow and then like nobody talks about it
because you
don't want to admit that this happened
to you so then
like these companies go in they get
screwed uh then the pharma companies go
in they get screwed hollywood goes in
was it
google supposed to go into china weren't
they making they were in
a chinese google search engine which
they scrapped and aren't they still
working on artificial intelligence with
the chinese government what's the story
with that
well so what happened with like uh back
in like 2000 was it seven eight nine
google was in china for a while uh and
they were trying to like kind of work
within the system you know censor some
stuff
but then like they hacked gmail and got
like
the uh information of a bunch of chinese
systems and they were and then they were
at
to their credit at the time we're like
we're uncensoring
our search kick us out of china and then
a few years later
they realized that well they removed
don't be evil from their
line and then they start secretly
working on a sentence
search app that's a really weird thing
to do for anyone
even if you were planning on being evil
wouldn't you at least lie
but to be like we've once said we didn't
want to be evil but now we're kind of
thinking you
can go either way huh it wasn't
interesting i wonder who was behind that
decision
they were like what happens if we have
to be evil
you know and then people are going to
yell at us let's just take it away and
then when we are evil we'll be like well
we got rid of that thing
that's why i don't blame them for what
they were doing i do think that google's
project dragonfly was one example of
something where
people made enough of a stink about it
that they could not
handle the bad pr and scrapped it yeah
even their employees were like what
because it was secret from the employees
right right right so
yeah that's a good example so the uh you
know go ahead
well so some somebody once framed it
from you
pretty clearly like if the chinese
communist party like actually like sent
in
planes and troops and tanks and like
took over the united states you know
started gutting it
the manufacturing gutting like all the
technology in silicon valley
replaced politicians people would freak
out and it would be like the biggest
bloodiest insurgency in history but they
did it quietly
with money and influence so the same
things are happening
they bought off a lot of people in
hollywood in the media
and the same things are happening
intellectual property theft
silicon valley uh so we have been
invaded just
what they call unrestricted warfare i'd
put it this way if
china invaded the us started seizing
large swaths of land
started compromising our politicians and
sleeping with certain california
congressmen
and uh stripping away intellectual
property rights and uh
basically you know using our own
companies against us
censoring our movies then then what
would happen is the american people i
tell you this because the american
people
are lazy and complacent they'd roll over
and be like well you know i'm not gonna
do anything about it
we literally have joe biden they say
is going to be the president on january
20th he's going to be inaugurated
and we've already had one of his former
family confidants tony babilinski come
out and say
i believe joe biden is compromised by
china
we have two investigations into the
biden family from jim biden joe's
brother
and hunter biden and we know for a fact
that joe biden himself
flew his son on air force two to china
for these private equity deals
my first question is i don't care what
you got to say about any of these
investigations
shouldn't we stop and be like why is joe
biden using government property to
enrich his son
why why did he bring his son on this
plane to negotiate this deal
that's suspect already father-son
bonding yeah
or outright and overt corruption by
which 80 million people will support it
so i tell you if the chinese were like
we're going to take over your country
you'd have
80 million people screaming and clapping
and cheering for it well they don't
how were they supposed to know about the
hunter buying thing the media like
that's actively censored that that's
social media we got smeared for covering
that actually we did yeah
that it was like that it was far right
russian disinformation yes
that's right despite the criminal
investigation that is actually going on
and
i mean and we knew about it yeah and
despite the email that happened in 2017
with hunter biden
asking a very chine a very famous
chinese energy tycoon
best wishes for the holidays and asking
him for 10 million dollars
or or where he said um we're trying to
get a room for
you know we're trying to get an office
for for everybody
including this you know chinese company
as well as joe and whatever they were
office mates i suppose
so look the the the there's enough i
would say circumstantial evidence
to in in my opinion warrant riots in the
streets
from the american people and they said
you had pitchforks here
yeah i have a squeegee that's as close
as i can get to something on a stick to
so the pitchfork was a lie yes it was
fake news i
i am disillusioned by this show i do
have matches though
they're the really good ones they're the
strike anywhere matches
so you can hold it up and you'll look
not nearly as angry
yeah you'll burn your fingers in like 20
seconds yeah
it's true i think you can't use that
analogy anymore about like uh
torches and pitchforks ever since ever
since the tiki torches became like
the wrong kind of thing you know what i
mean oh yeah but uh but
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you